Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of
the Decent. I'm your host, Ricard Loops.
And today I'm joined by Doctor Steven Grossberg. He
is Wang, professor of Cognitive and neuro Systems,
Professor Emeritus of Mathematics and Statistics, psychological and brain
sciences and biomedical engineering at Boston University. And today
we're focusing on one of his books, the latest
one. And I guess that Steve would agree with
me when I say that it's probably his magnum opus
conscious mind, resonant brain. How each brain makes
a mind. So, Steve, welcome to the
show. It's an honor to everyone. Well,
it's a delight to be here and it's one of
the wonders of modern zoom that you're in Portugal and
I'm in Newton Massachusetts. So there we go.
Yeah. There we go. It's modern technology,
right? Yeah. Which got really amplified greatly when
COVID happened. That's when zoom really took off.
Yeah, that, that's totally right. So to
get into the topics here, then I, in
the first few sections of your book, you get
into how we tackle basically the brain, how we
understand the brain, the mind and the relationship between
them and how you can do it through several different
perspectives, mostly you focus on physics and psychology.
So to introduce the topic, could you tell us
perhaps and also to add some historical background here for
the audience? Could you tell us how uh physics
and psychology approach approach this issue? And historically,
when and how did they split in their approaches?
Yeah. Well, at the um in the late
18 hundreds, uh three very great physicists Helmholtz,
I'm sorry, Hermann, Von Helmholtz in Germany,
Clerk Maxwell in England and Ernst Mach in Austria made
seminal contributions to psychology and neuroscience. Uh At that
time, if you were interested in the structure of
physical space and time, you would just as likely
try to study psychological space and time. But um
so they were uh interested in understanding how the observed
world which is physics developed side by side their analysis
of the observer, which is us. But by
the time we got to the young Albert Einstein,
oh, he didn't do psychology anymore. He just
did physics. And I wanna quote just a little
thing that he wrote to his friend, Queen Elizabeth
of Belgium in 1933 which was much later. But
this was his stance throughout life that quote, most
of us prefer to look outside rather than inside ourselves
. For in the latter case we see but a
dark hole which means nothing at all. So in
the late 18 hundreds of the greatest physicists did psychology
and physics and some neuroscience. And then Einstein who's
at least is great and did only physics. And
the question is why. And one main reason is
due to the properties of the experimental data that Helmholtz
Maxwell and Mach uh discovered. And that data has
characteristics that I like saying a nonlinear non stationary and
non local. Whereas traditional physics use models that are
linear stationary and local. So what do those words
mean? Well, nonlinear means uh in the simplest
form, the whole isn't the sum of its parts
. You know, you chop us up into parts
and life is no longer supported. But nonlinearity more
technically means that you multiply variables. You don't just
add them linear means you just add stuff non stationary
means we're always evolving from being babies. We develop
quickly and then we go on through lifelong learning and
non local in the sense that I'm using it means
that there are long range interactions between many, many
neurons in our brains. And that is because these
interactions enable our brains to understand the context and the
objects in which we experience the world is not just
pixel by pixel in a painting that our brains look
at the whole pattern which requires interactions. Uh And
uh the physicists just didn't have the concepts or the
math to do it. And in fact, Helmholz
, who started out deeply interested in psychology and physiology
ended his life only doing physics. So maybe that's
enough to get started. And of course, when
I asked you here about how people from physics and
psychology, for example, think about or understand the
brain, the mind and the relationship. I was
also at least to some extent alluding to the mind
body problem. So, could you tell us what
exactly is the mind body problem and why has it
been so difficult to tackle? Ok. Well,
when we think of our brain, which is a
central feature in our body and the one that's relevant
to our discussion today, we may think of the
little gray cells of Hercule Poirot. I don't know
if you like mysteries, but I always loved thinking
about the little gray cells, but we think of
our mind, we may think about a beautiful sunset
, a feeling of being in love, uh you
know, deep thoughts or poetry. And there's a
huge gap between those two. And the question is
, how do you bridge the gap? And that's
what my magnum opus uh tries to do as reflected
by its title Conscious Mind Resonant Brain. How each
brain makes a mind? How do we bridge the
gap? And my book therefore, tries to have
a comprehensive and unified description of the main processes whereby
our brains make our minds. And that can be
done because there are vast databases that were accumulated in
psychology and neuroscience uh since the time of Helm Helmholtz
Maxwell and Max. So the problem wasn't um what
am I supposed to explain the problem was how can
I find any explanation of hundreds of experiments and which
experiments cohere together? So in order to even even
begin this, you have to have an intuition in
which data uh are probing the same underlying processes.
And what are those processes? So? Well,
we start with perception and at least two main ones
, visual and auditory. I won't even talk about
tactile and that goes on to cognition and emotion and
action. And we can't just be satisfied with discussing
how that goes on in uh healthy or typical individuals
. It's important to also understand well, what happens
when they break down which they do and can lead
to many clinical disorders. And in the course of
my work, I noticed that if there's certain imbalances
or breakdowns in the neural network processes that I used
to model lots of uh data about typical individuals in
a principled and unifying way. Then al popped uh
symptoms of diseases as varied as Alzheimer's disease, autism
, medial temporal amnesia, schizophrenia, A DH D
PTSD, auditory and visual neglect and agnosia. Even
what goes wrong with slow wave sleep things which I
never dreamed of. And so one of the main
things to think about is, you know, how
are you forced into thinking about things you never dreamed
you would know anything about. And more than that
um our brains operate in cycles as a perception,
cognition, emotion action cycle where we're continually interacting with
and adapting to a rapidly changing environment. So with
this background, let's come down back to the mind
body problem. Why are they so intimately linked?
And one theme in my book and, and think
about mind body problem is brain evolution needs to achieve
behavioral success. So the uh the meat, the
little gray cells, uh the body part of it
is intimately linked through Darwinian selection to uh the mind
part of it. Uh They, they can't be
separated. Um So the book explains how multiple brain
circuits and multiple brain regions interact to generate the behaviors
that control our day to day uh activities and mind
is what you can most efficiently call an emergent property
, an interactive property of these brain mechanisms. And
even Von Neumann knew that that the intelligence isn't just
in the local interaction, it's how many of them
interact. So why my book is unusual is that
most books are about mind or brain, but not
about each brain makes a mind. And in this
regard, I was lucky because I started my life's
work when I was 17 years old, I was
a freshman taking introductory psychology. And there was a
lot of quantitative data about how we learn a classical
data, Hovland Hall. Many other Great American psychologists
were into learning. And so my brain exploded and
I was driven into what became neural networks uh including
the main laws of short term memory, medium term
memory, long term memory that people use today to
explain how brains make minds. So because I started
in psychology and was forced into brain, I was
able to make the link and then build and build
and build with many gifted collaborators for 67 years.
So it was a lucky start. But why my
brain exploded, I can't explain. And um so
um and these are not traditional concepts from computer science
, engineering or traditional symbolic A I, although now
a lot of people call me the father of A
I. Because over the years when symbolic A I
failed, the people in IA I wanted to take
over neural networks to be A I. Marvin Minsky
was one of them. And um anyway, so
I'm called the father of A I because I introduced
the modern paradigm in 1957. Um And along the
way, you know, with all the discoveries that
just poured out uh over these years, uh it's
not just classical stuff because I had to introduce new
computational paradigms to link brain to mind. And I
call two of them complementary computing and laminar computing and
complementary computing explains the nature of brain specialization. You
know, we don't have independent modules like you don't
first compute uh edges and then shading and then texture
and then depth rather. When we look at an
object, all of these properties can be overlaid,
we're looking at a texture depth, full object with
contours boundaries. And so there's a lot of multiplexing
of um properties. And so um complementary computing was
a discovery I gradually made. I didn't wake up
one day and say, oh let's let's assume the
brain as complementary computing. Now I over decades,
I we try to explain more and more data and
in every one of them, there were complementary pairs
of processes and a kind of Yin Yang relationship computationally
complementary until I realized it was a global design principle
for the brain. Like I think we might come
to it in a while that visual boundaries and surfaces
obey computationally complementary laws. The ventral watt stream that
um does perception and recognition in our brain and the
dorsal we stream that the facial representation and action obey
computational complementary laws. And one of them the what
and where is on a huge scale of atomical organization
and the boundaries and surfaces are much smaller. So
you have a multilevel um uh representation of complimentary complementarity
in all brain processes. And I mentioned lam in
a computer and laminar computing explains how all uh higher
forms of biological intelligence are um explained by variations of
a single canonical Lain a circuit. I mean some
listeners may know that if you look at uh the
Neocortex that supports vision, speech language cognition, there
are six characteristic layers and characteristic sub lamina with characteristic
feedback interactions and horizontal interactions. So bottom up,
top down horizontal in all of these circuits. And
one of the marvels of evolution is that specializations of
the same canonical circuit can do vision, speech language
and cognition. And that's very important when you think
, how do we develop a sense of self cause
our whole cortex shares a design and all the parts
can seamlessly fit together into an emergent uh architecture that
can be resonating uh as needed to do, you
know everything that we do in our conscious experience.
So I've always felt it was remarkable that some such
seemingly different behavioral competences emerge out of variations of this
ship canonical circuit. And no less remarkable is that
circuit supports different kinds of conscious awareness. And because
all those circuits obey a similar kind of input output
scheme, so they can all be interacted, feed
forward feedback, et cetera that supports consciousness. Um
But maybe that's all I should say about that you
have a lot of questions you want me to answer
. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. There's
a lot there to unpack and it relates to also
to some of the questions that I have also say
for listeners, I think, you know, think
of this interview as listening to his story, everything
in the story can be thought about and studied on
multiple levels. But first get the gist of the
story and, and maybe as we go along,
uh you'll ask me to flesh out things more but
, but your questions really asked me to flesh things
out more. So I, I think we should
follow the questions and then see what made the needs
to be added. Of course. And so uh
you've mentioned words like and computation there. And I
would like to perhaps clarify that a little bit more
. So, are our brains like computers? I
mean, when people talk about com brains as computers
, when they use that metaphor, is it accurate
or not? Well emphatically not. Um If I
start, I just noted we need new computational paradigms
. Uh like complementary computing, laminate computing. Uh
Moreover, traditional computers aren't conscious. Um So my
work provides or off as a scientific solution, the
mind body problem by showing how where in our brains
and even why from a deep computational perspective, humans
can consciously see here, feel and know things about
the world. And we don't just get conscious to
serenely contemplate the beauty of the world rather we use
our conscious states for reasons I hope will clarify as
we go along because they are competent to uh um
control uh effective planning and action to realize valued goals
. And so consciousness mediates between mind and the world
of action. Um And so to do this,
our brains are self organizing, meaning we can learn
by ourselves autonomously throughout life. Their analog, which
means that the neurons can have values going from minimum
to max and everything in between, not namely shades
of gray, much as you might see an achromatic
image in shades of gray and everything operates in parallel
because everything about our intelligence is organized in terms of
spatially distributed patterns of activation. So self-organizing analog parallel
, but present day computers are not self-organizing and they're
digital and serial. So the architectures are fundamentally different
. Um My own belief is that as uh computers
evolve and they are, you know, they get
even more powerful, like, you know, my
iphone is a supercomputer. Um We have systems that
on the one hand, uh maybe dedicated VL SI
chips that embody more and more of the kind of
intelligence that humans embody are complemented by a lot of
things humans don't do well, which digital computers do
like adding a million numbers in a fraction of a
second. And that will be a very powerful tool
when when and if it happens. And uh you've
already mentioned their uh conscious awareness. How do we
experience conscious moments of seeing, hearing, feeling,
knowing and why do things like perception and awareness uh
matter here? Well, I wanna emphasize that although
I've led the development of what I think is arguably
the most advanced neural theory of consciousness in the sense
that it provides principal and unifying explanations of the most
psychological and or biological data about conscious experiences. I
never tried to directly understand consciousness. Uh You don't
wake up in the morning and say, hey,
you know, let's understand consciousness today. Uh But
instead all the deepest insights about how our brains work
a concern. One of the things I just mentioned
how they self organize uh through childhood development. And
do you have any kids? Uh No, not
yet. At least. Well, we have one
daughter. Well, anyone who has observed little kids
learn language that's fast self organization and lifelong learning.
We continue learning throughout life. Remarkably. Uh My
models of learning led me forced me kicking and screaming
into insights about consciousness. And uh so my work
on learning led to the most advanced, currently,
the most advanced cognitive and neural the about how brains
learn to pay attention, recognize and predict objects and
events in a changing world emphatically. One that's filled
with unexpected events because that's what we got to do
to deal with evolutionary challenges. And this is the
theory I call adaptive resonance theory for a reason.
I'll make clear in a moment and all of the
foundational hypotheses have uh from which I could derive art
have been supported by subsequent psychological and neurobiological data.
And art has also provided principled and unifying explanations of
many additional experiments. But for me, the bottom
line is really that I was able to derive art
. I say art A RT instead of adaptive Resonance
theory in 1980 in an off cited article in the
journal Psychological Ro review from a thought experiment. And
this thought experiment is about how any learning system can
autonomously learn to correct predictive errors. So this is
all about autonomous learning and the hypotheses of the thought
experiment are just a few facts that are familiar to
us all. And they're familiar because they represent ubiquitous
environmental pressures on the evolution of our brain. So
they're not something. Oh, well, why should
I believe that? You believe it because you've been
living with it your whole life. And moreover,
during the thought experiment, I never used the word
mind or brain. Mhm. So, the thought
experiment and the principles and mechanisms that come out of
the wash are thus the universal solution to the learning
problem. Wherever those hypotheses are used to derive their
logical consequences, you'll get a system like art and
the learning problem, which I didn't say one crucial
fact about lifelong learning implies that when I learn something
, I won't just forget it right away, which
is called catastrophic forgetting. For example, Ricardo,
I never uh saw your face before and now I'll
remember it for the rest of my life. So
I learn it in a second. I'll remember it
for years. So I call this the stability plasticity
dilemma. How any system can learn without catastrophe,
forgetting plasticity of because we experience incredibly fast learning often
and then stability. The fact that our memory of
that fast learning can persist for a very long time
. And let me just say, for those of
you who know some popular current A I like deep
learning or it experiences catastrophic forgetting big time in multiple
ways. Uh If we maybe we will talk about
a little later. So I think therefore, it's
remarkable. But that these results about learning without catastrophic
forgetting is what led me to rigorous neural models of
how we consciously see, hear and feel and know
things about the world. So I derive the models
I was explaining with simulation, parametric quantitative computer simulations
with my many students and postdoc all this quantitative data
about seeing, hearing, feeling and knowing. And
then I realized all those parametric properties or properties of
conscious experiences. So consciousness sort of came in through
the back door. Uh And the thing that all
of these experiences had in common are resonances which occur
when there's excitatory feedback bottom up, top down excitatory
feedback between pairs or greater numbers of brain regions when
they match their signals well enough to cause the active
cells to synchronize boom, boom, boom, boom
, boom, boom, boom, boom. Um
And that's one reason why we have brain rhythms,
but different brain rhythms support different processes and sustain.
They're firing long enough to trigger not only learning but
consciousness. In other words, the resonances and the
requirement for matching or what dynamically buffer a learning process
against catastrophic forgetting. And the remarkable thing is that
the contents of these resonances match properties of the conscious
experiences that they're learning to represent. That's why I
call my theory adaptive resonance theory because of how resonances
trigger learning that doesn't experience catastrophic forgetting. So the
proposed solution on mind body problem occurs due to a
computational analysis of how humans and other animals autonomously learn
in a changing world without catastrophic forgetting. And because
the hypotheses and the thought experiments that lead to cognitive
models like adaptive resonance theory, as well as cognitive
emotional models, like what I call my cog and
model, the cognitive emotional motor model never mentioned the
word mind and brain. Um My work and my
book show how these models provide a blueprint for designing
autonomous adaptive intelligent applications to engineering technology and A I
. So if you want autonomous adaptive intelligence, we
already have the foundations of a blueprint for it for
the future. Um In particular, my books spend
a lot of time uh explaining how our brains consciously
see the world. And that's not surprising because more
than half of various mammalian brains are devoted to vision
from excuse me, early sensory processing up to visually
based cognitive planning and navigation. Um In other words
, we need perception and consciousness to be able to
act upon the world by looking, reaching and navigating
uh in order to survive environmental challenges. So this
link between consciousness and action I think is very interesting
mediated by learning that solves the stability plasticity dilemma.
Sorry about this. I have had asthma for over
70 years. Uh So uh another thing that I
would like to ask you about and it's something that
you also tackle in the book is Visual Illusion.
So how do they work and what can we learn
about? I guess not only the visual system but
information processing by understanding how visual illusions work. Yeah
, I wish we were able to figure out how
to show my powerpoint slides. I'll try to use
the words uh about what the pictures would have shown
more clearly. So first let me sketch why we
experience visual illusions, which will also start to explain
how they work. Um So let's start with the
retina, the photosensitive retina, that's where light is
registered before light signals all over the retina are bundled
through axons as the pathways uh into the optic nerve
to set pattern light from the whole retina up to
the brain because of the need to form the optic
nerve to carry the light signals to the brain.
The retina has no photo detectors on the part of
the retina where the optic nerve forms, that part
of the retina is blind. And um you might
say, well, big deal, I don't see
it, it hasn't caused any trouble. But if
you look down on the retina and I had a
pretty picture to show you that. And if you
get my book, um it has all these pictures
, it has over 600 color pictures. So everything
I say is illustrated, another part of the retina
not far from the blind spot is called the fovea
Fove A. That's where all of our high acuity
vision occurs. And it's because we need the phia
to really see things clearly that we move our eyes
several times every second with psychotic eye movements to point
them to the things we really wanna see clearly.
Things in the periphery get fuzzier and fuzzier and the
blind spot is as big as the phobia. And
now you might say, but then why don't I
see it? And um, before getting into,
why think about it, we couldn't look at or
reach for an object that happened to re registered where
the blind spot is. If we didn't somehow do
something to make that problem go away and that could
lead to disaster, you know, a leopard is
leaping at you in the place where the blind spot
would have seen it tough. So why aren't we
aware of the missing visual signals due to the blind
spot in particular, how do you complete the retina
representation so that we can look at and reach for
things which otherwise might have been uh invisible. And
one thing you have to deal with right away is
our eyes are rapidly jiggling in the orbit. They're
sort of micro the cards and they're happening so fast
and they're so small, you don't notice it,
but it's functionally very important because there may be a
stationary object in the world and you are stationary with
respect to it. But your retina is jiggling back
and forth around every edge of that object and it's
creating transient signals. Um And these transient signals,
refresh visual signals um which otherwise would fade. I
like to mention Jurassic Park here. And did you
see Jurassic Park? Yes, I do. You
know that famous scene where um this guy is standing
out of the car and T Rex comes looking very
ravenous and they scream, stand still. He can
only see relative motion and then T Rex moves his
head. Yes, relative motion and scoops them up
in one bite. Anyway, the blind spot is
stabilized on the retina. So it doesn't create transients
and so it fades. So it's not gonna cause
a problem in itself, but you still have uh
an incomplete retina limit with a big hole in it
. And so how do you complete that? And
that is comp accomplished by multiple stages of completing boundaries
across the hall and fill in with surface brightness and
color. And it takes several stages to do it
. Um And I call processes whereby incomplete representations are
completed by multiple stages of processing a hierarchical resolution of
uncertainty because when you're done, you're going to get
completed boundaries and completed surface representations. So you don't
know there was a hole there. Mhm But then
that raises a deep question. How does the brain
know at what stage the cortical representation say of a
surface representing your face is complete enough uh to um
control looking at you or maybe touching your nose?
How do you know what stage? Because it took
a lot of stages. And you don't want to
use a stage that has an incomplete representation because then
the leopard could leap at you through your blind spot
. And the answer that I propose is that a
resonance with a completed surface representation. And the next
processing stage. Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
surface representation. Next stage lights up the surface representation
makes it consciously visible. And then we use the
conscious representation to look and reach. And so the
hierarchical resolution of uncertainty created the need to have some
active process light up the completed representation. And I
call this a surface shroud resonance because spatial attention focusing
on the surface is called a intentional shroud. And
I predict it occurs between a pre stride visual cortex
V four. In other words, there's a hierarchy
of cortical stages. It took several days stages to
complete the surface and the posterior parietal cortex which is
known to support spatial attention. So V four P
PC I predict supports the surface route resonance and there's
a lot of data supporting that. So getting back
to the original question, what's a visual illusion?
If the boundaries that are completed do not contain expected
surface brightness and colors, then we say we're looking
at a visual illusion. The truth is that almost
everything we see is a visual illusion in the sense
that we're completing boundaries and surfaces not only over the
blind spot also over the plexus of retinal veins that
covers the photo detectors. In addition, where compensating
for variable illumination, we not seeing the illumination gradient
. So the final representation of objects and scenes are
visual illusions, but we only say, oh that's
a visual illusion. If the color isn't what it
we think it should be based on our experience with
that kind of boundary. So everything basically in vision
is an illusion and the ones that look funny,
we call illusions. OK? But about those ones
that look funny and we call illusions. How does
understanding how we experience those connect to our experience of
art? Well, here, I would have shown
you several pictures that would have been uh let people
listening. We weren't able to figure out how to
link my powerpoint to the zoom. I've done it
in the past, but I think the software changed
or something. I don't know. First, I
want to say a little bit more about boundaries and
surfaces because they are the general functional units of how
we see. That's an early prediction of mine that
various people and supported psychophysics. So, um there's
a wonderful uh illusion that it's painful to me not
to be able to show it to you because it's
gonna be so hard to explain is a certain kind
of Kinnier Square, Gaetano Kita famously introduced lots of
visual illusions. He's very great uh Italian perceptual psychologist
who died some years ago in this illusion. He
takes um circles and he'll make part of the circle
black and part of it light blue in a lot
of concentric circles so that the black blue interface is
horizontal. But I'll make a Pacman out of it
where the black part has a Pacman shape. These
are all black lines and then there's a little quarter
of it, which is the blue parts which have
less contrast and he'll do four of them, 12
parallel to each other, like oriented three. It
is hard to do, but it's backwards. So
we'll have pairs in a row and then pairs one
on top of the other. And so if you
look at where the black and blue uh interfaces occur
, they all line up to form an illusory square
and my book has it. I don't know if
you can see it. Yes. Yes, I
can. Yes. So you see the point is
that because of the bound, the strong black boundaries
inhibiting the weak blue boundaries, that's enough to make
the square form. And it's also enough to let
surface color pour out of the broken blue boundary to
fill in the entire square. So what you see
is a blue square, neither the blue nor the
square are in the image. But what this illustrates
and that's why it's such a lovely example. Boundaries
are completed inwardly between pairs or greater numbers of inducers
in an oriented way. That's how you complete the
square and the blue color that spills out of the
little blue uh broken boundaries spreads in a uh un
oriented way um to fill in the square. So
um so the color spreads outwardly and un oriented and
the boundaries are completed inwardly and oriented. And so
you could see from this outward, inward oriented,
un oriented, a sense of what I mean,
that boundaries and surfaces are complementary and, and Yang
, because you can't be both oriented and un oriented
and you can't be both outward and inward and without
both of them interacting though you don't see anything.
And so you have these parallel cortical streams that are
doing complementary computing and then interacting to overcome their complementary
deficiencies. And there's one more big property of boundaries
and surfaces. For starters, we can consciously see
surface brightness and color we see while the, but
we can't consciously see boundaries except when they separate surfaces
with different brightness and color boundaries are invisible. It's
called the offset grading. Uh Yes. OK.
So all I've drawn is horizontal black lines, but
usually you can recognize that there's a vertical boundary of
some kind between the ends of those lines. Can
you recognize that? So, but the boundary is
invisible? OK. All boundaries are invisible. The
only reason why you'll see color is because if you
create uh let me see if you can see this
. Whoops. Uh uh Yes, I can,
I can. This is called the Ehrenstein disk.
All I drew were black lines. It completed a
roughly circular boundary, perpendicular lines. And then at
the line ends, there were little black white contrasts
that were little brightness buttons that filled in within the
boundary, the circular boundary and makes it look brighter
. Do you see? It looks brighter? Yes
, I see. OK. So that's a case
where because the color can't escape, it makes for
a visible brightness difference, but here the color can
escape because it can flow all out of there and
spread uniformly on both sides of the vertical boundary.
And so it's invisible. So I let me show
you, I think I wanna show you a very
famous picture. That's a lot of fun. Let
me see. This is a famous picture uh perhaps
just please move it a little bit away from the
camera because OK, like that like that, I
don't know if you can see, I can see
first, it looks just like splotches of black on
white. But if you look at it for a
while, you can see a Dalmatian dog in snow
. It's hard to do the image all the way
to my right is the kita square. Mhm I
don't know if you can see. Yes, I
can see and right next to it horizontally, what's
called a reverse contrast kita square? Now the Kinnier
square just like uh when I made that circle with
the lines, it looks brighter because the Pac Man
, the four pac men create square boundaries and then
they put bright contrast inside which fill in the square
and look brighter. But if you look at the
one right next to it, it has two black
and two white inducers on gray background. And there
you can recognize that there is a square but the
gray inside and outside of the square is the same
. So it's visible. So in the case of
the reverse contrast, Ken it a square, I'm
so sorry, I should have just made. No
, no, no worries. I can edit this
. Yeah. So you can consciously recognize a a
square boundary that you don't see. Um Anyway,
many artists knew uh instinctively about these things, including
matisse who I love and matisse used to like writing
that all bound. Well, he didn't write all
boundaries are invisible, but he painted with color blotches
and knowing that the boundaries would be completed to create
a scene. And one of my favorites is the
self care and I leave it, leave it like
that, please. Yeah. Yeah. He painted
that in uh 1905. And if you see it
uh in my book or on the web or wherever
you'll see that there are a lot of color splotches
, but they're arranged in a way that invisible boundaries
join them and create surface representations of objects. So
let me see if I can, they get the
schematic of that. Yes, I can see it
now. Yeah, you see the splotches create a
modal boundary groupings which then capture the splotches into surface
color. So, OK, anyway, so um
that is one link between art and um illusions.
And I discussed the work of 14 different artists showing
how they all instinctively exploited different properties of how we
see. I mean, just consider like uh the
impressionists like Monet and Point Allistic painting sera. Um
you know how these little points of color arranged uh
in an appropriate way, generated emergent boundaries and surfaces
that you can interpret as a beautiful scene. So
uh my book spends a lot of time showing how
different artists and artistic movements um uh generated uh painterly
precepts that we understand often as scenes and objects even
, you know, and like how you get effects
of three dimensional curvature in a two D painting.
And one of the big things my book explains is
how the way our visual system adapted to the three
dimensional world, those same laws automatically enable us to
understand paintings. Um zoom screen movies as 3d objects
. You know, I'm not seeing you like a
pancake, I'm seeing a frontal view of a three
dimensional face. And so we've been talking here a
lot about the visual system, but how do we
go from seeing to recognizing and also then to predicting
the world? Um So first let's distinguish, seeing
and recognizing. So seeing, we open our eyes
and if there's enough light we'll see, it could
be unfamiliar or familiar. Uh So seeing is a
general purpose process, but we only recognize familiar things
. So recognition requires prior learning of recognition categories for
objects and scenes. Uh so that these categories would
selectively fire after learning in response to the objects and
scenes that we've experienced before. And that raises the
question, how do you learn a recognition category?
And I already noted that Adaptive Resonance Theory or art
explains how we learn to recognize stuff without experiencing catastrophic
forgetting. And one thing I didn't say about learning
in what I said, it enables us to pay
attention. But what it's what we're learning as we're
learning categories that can be used for prediction is what
are the critical feature combinations that are going to predict
uh successful action? How do we suppress the irrelevant
outliers? And when you study adaptive residency, you
see how over learning trials outlier, irrelevant features get
actively suppressed and you gradually converge it can be very
fast. It depends on the complexity of the problem
on a set of critical features in the activation pattern
. Uh that you know, the top down expectation
is lighting up and it's so critical features that go
into the bottom up adaptive filters that choose the category
and in the top down expectation that the category reads
out to focus attention. And so the critical features
enable art categories to be associated with predictive consequences.
Um Yeah. So and so and different resonances then
support seeing and recognizing I mentioned mhm A surface shroud
resonance supports conscious seeing and uh the shroud is in
posterior parietal cortex. Um the surfaces in V four
, when that resonance occurs, it propagates top down
all the way down to uh lateral chani it all
the way up to prefrontal cortex. And because of
what's called the art matching room, namely how we
pay attention. It selects the critical features that uh
we should be looking at. But then the feature
category resonance um which goes into the watch stream,
recognition and perception stream that supports conscious knowing. So
that when a surface shroud resonance and a feature category
resonance synchronize, when I look at a familiar person's
face, I both see them and know who they
are. Um And I had a nice, nice
picture of that. But if, if you're interested
anyway about my book, if you are interested,
I I should say this because, you know,
you might think such a big book. Uh If
you buy it on Kindle, it's 15 bucks.
And if you buy it from Amazon, it's about
30 it would have cost over 100. But I
worked very hard on the book and I want the
people who are interested to be able to afford it
. So I I asked Oxford University Press how much
of my own money I had to give them to
bring the prices down. So if you get it
, it's cheap because I subsidized it. Well,
thank you so much for that. That's very generous
. I guess that people will be. How much
did it cost in Portugal? Yeah, I don't
know why the, the you, you use euros
in Portugal. Uh, y yes, I,
I mean, I, I think it cost around
, uh, I don't know,30 I guess
I um order it from Amazon Spain. So,
yeah, so that's not that different from$30.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, that's right. That's
right. Well, thank you for buying it.
So um should we, should we move on?
Uh Yes. Uh And I was going to ask
you now, uh actually earlier, you've mentioned for
example, your uh cognition, emotion motor model.
But how do you look at the relationship between emotion
and cognition and brave cognition about is what we know
about the world and emotion embodies, how we feel
about what we know. And it's emotion that gives
value to what we know. And here another resonance
occurs between our cognitive alike representations and our emotional representations
. So the alike ones are in places like infra
temporal and prefrontal cortex. The emotional ones are in
places like the Amygdala and hypothalamus. And when there's
a resonance between cognitive and emotional uh representations that combines
what we know with how we feel about it.
And the feedback from the emotional representation is called incentive
motivation. Not only to pay sustained attention to something
that we currently value, but it also gives the
motivation to release actions to realize goals about things we
value. So, you know, if I see
my wife's face a little way from here, I'll
feel all the good things I feel to her and
the motivation to approach her. So a cognitive emotional
resonance sends positive feedback between the cognitive and emotional representations
. So just as a current object or event can
trigger an emotion, an active emotion can select and
focus attention on objects and events that are compatible with
that emotion. And that can help us achieve,
you know, um results that are compatible with it
where emotion could be hunger and we just wanna go
have lunch. So um how to notice desire attend
and eat that ice cream cone. It's all wrapped
up into cognitive emotional resonances in their output pathways.
Um So the cognitive emotional resonance is a different kind
of consciousness because it links, for example, um
to surface shroud resonance. Well, I think we're
gonna talk about that in a moment. So,
so I I mean, these different kinds of awareness
that we have and we've talked about some of them
, how, how are they then integrated into what
we experience as unified moments of conscious awareness? Yeah
. So for that multiple adaptive resonance is synchronized.
I mentioned two of them that could. But so
example, during a conversation with a friend, we
might be synchronizing surface shroud residents to consciously see them
stream shroud resonances that consciously hear them feature category resonances
to consciously recognize what we're hearing. Cognitive emotional resonance
is to consciously have feelings about what we're discussing and
then what's called item list resonances to consciously understand the
conversation because they're supporting things like working memory of sequential
sounds that form language phrases and sentences, and all
of them come together to enable us to act appropriately
during the conversation. So it's not just a single
resonance, there's a continually evolving series of resident states
as stuff keeps happening. And so uh we've already
talked here about the relationship between cognition and emotion.
Uh I would like to ask you now specifically about
the prefrontal cortex. So, in all of what
we've been talking about here, does the prefrontal cortex
play a special role? Um Well, I'm gonna
want to show you a figure of that for sure
. But, but first, let me say it
carries out or controls many of the higher cognitive,
emotional and decision making processes that define human intelligence as
it's also controlling release of actions uh and aimed at
achieving value gold. And as I just mentioned,
one of the things prefrontal cortex has it has um
working memories that can uh generate uh what I call
um list chunks or list categories like words, sentences
, phrases, thoughts that can sequentially determine what's appropriate
to do in a given situation. So it's not
just one thing and it enabled us to generate behaviors
that are flexible and adaptive notably in novel situations and
to suppress ones that aren't by using this contextual knowledge
. Um Can you see the seven regions on top
in red and green? Uh uh Yeah, I
, I mean the green, it's not perceptible here
. But yeah, I see the, the several
regions on top, they're all different regions of prefrontal
cortex. And basically, when you put together all
the models into this larger neural architecture, it explains
how the prefrontal cortex interacts with uh cognitive emotional decision
making processes to make contextually based decisions about what to
do or think next. So it's uh so you
got to understand how working memories work and a whole
series of things we won't discuss much today. So
earlier, you've mentioned learning and I want to ask
you a little bit more about it because actually in
the book, you also explain why we need to
understand learning to then properly understand consciousness. And you
distinguish between two different types of learning, perceiving and
knowing versus moving and navigating. How do they differ
from one another? Right. Well, so I
briefly mentioned before that perception and cognition are represented in
the w or ventral uh cortical stream and then a
spatial organization in action including navigation of representing the where
or dorsal cortical stream. And um uh they obey
computationally complementary laws. I'm gonna just say in words
what they are. And then it may be that
one of the sly, one of the um copies
I was trying to make in my powerpoint was of
that. And I can actually show it. I'll
run that to my other study. So perception and
cognition, use exci toy matching and match based learning
. What does that mean? So if I read
out a top down expectation, um a prime the
system for getting ready to respond more vigorously to an
expected event, oh, you're here, I recognize
your face faster. So that's excitatory matching and match
based learning means that you only go into adaptive resonance
if what you're expecting and what you're learning about uh
c close enough together. So you can suppress stuff
and learn a better and better critical feature pattern.
So the learning is ex excited to it's match based
and the matching is side to it. But navigation
and action use inhibitory matching and mismatch based learning.
What is an inhibitory match, let's say within our
movement, I have a representation of where my hand
is now and I wanted to go here. So
this is my present position. This is my target
position. Then I have a volitional go signal from
the basal ganglia that makes my arm move from here
to here. But when I get here, I
am where I wanna be. So that present target
minus present is zero, that's inhibitory matching. And
it turns out you use that mismatch in an appropriate
way to tune the circuit so that when you are
, where you wanna be the difference vector is zero
. So first here, I can't see what I'm
showing you I can see it, here's a slide
of adaptive resonance and you can see the light green
down here. Yes, that's the critical feature pattern
so that you have a top down match on the
critical feature pattern. You go through an excitatory resonance
to try to learn that. And the way that
works if we're gonna discuss it is via the art
matching rule. Uh move it just a little bit
to your left, please. Yes, like that
. Yes. So the what the art matching rule
shows, you see, there's, if I have
bottom up excited Tory input, it can fire a
feature selective cells. If nothing else is happening,
if I activate a category and I try to read
out in those spreading green adapted pathways, uh AAA
critical feature pattern or prototype, I can't fully do
it because I'm also activating this inhibitory of surround which
approximately balances the excitatory on center. That's how I
prime. When I read out that, that expectation
, there might be some subthreshold activation of the cells
that got activated and a deep trough of inhibition around
it. But then if I have a matching bottom
up input, it's two against one, too excited
to one bottom up, one top down one inhibitory
, you can start to fire and that can lead
to resonance. And I don't know if we discuss
, we're gonna discuss that. Uh What do you
do if something unexpected happens? There's a complimentary attentional
system and orienting system where the learning goes on the
attentional system. And if you get a big enough
mismatch or novelty or unexpectedness, it activates the oriented
system which automatically discovers a better matching category or a
new category to learn the new stuff. So,
OK, that was a little a field. So
sorry, let's get back to your question. Uh
So then, I mean, why is it,
why do we need to understand learning then to properly
understand consciousness? Well, to summarize my work shows
that learning without catastrophic forgetting is solved by adaptive resonances
. And that properties of the adaptive resonances just after
years of modeling happen to support multiple conscious states with
different functions in different parts of the brain. We
reviewed some of them, all of them are supported
by lots of explanations of modeling simulations and explanations of
data. So, um you know, science is
never complete but um uh I'm I'm sort of baffled
in a way, you know, we live in
the world of Google, you can presumably search for
anything in no time at all. And yet I've
explained data from hundreds of experiments. Never mentioning the
word quantum no quantum. Um There were quantum effects
at the photoreceptors at the when you know noise hits
the the ear at the periphery right away, our
brains are designed to suppress quantum noise and to deal
with it to become deterministic. And yet today,
there are still people who are promoting that, you
know, consciousness must be quantum because they don't understand
it and must be in microtubules. So how do
you recite Keats out of a microtubule? That's beyond
my understanding. So there's overwhelming evidence that what I'm
saying is at least on the road to the truth
and the thought experiments cannot be denied because the hypotheses
are familiar facts. Um When I grew up learning
science, I thought you studied the theories that explain
the most data in a principled way and nothing comes
close. So I hope some people are interested in
studying it. And I wrote my book in particular
to be self-contained and non technical. But that being
said, we are talking about the human mind,
which is perhaps the most complex system in nature that
we can hope to understand scientifically. So uh it
requires thoughtful reading. I have friends who've read it
uh parts of it, you know, who know
no science at all. Um a rabbi, a
pastor, a, a visual artist, a gallery
owner, a lawyer, the social worker. Um
and they would read the parts that interest them and
, and that's possible because I wrote the chapter.
So after you read the preface and introductory chapter,
one, each chapter can be read independently of the
others. So you don't have to try to read
the whole thing who has that much time or interest
. But you know, if you're interested in about
feelings, you can jump to the chapter about feelings
and so on. So let me ask you now
a little bit about the evolution of the brain.
And actually earlier, you've already touched a little bit
on the idea or the proposal that some people have
of modularity. But what do you think about that
idea more specifically about the idea of modularity of the
brain slash mind? Well, brain anatomy is definitely
specialized. There are multiple brain regions that carry out
different functions like vision, audition, cognition, emotion
, and so on. But the processes aren't carried
out by independent modules. In fact, if you
look at f the famous Feldman and Van Essen macro
circuit, which I had a picture of um they
all interact. Um I can't, you see,
I can't see it when, when you can see
it. Yes, but I can see it.
Yes. OK. So on the one hand in
the lower right, that's the anatomical diagram by Feldman
and Van Een of the interactions in the visual system
dense bottom up, top down multiple stages. Remember
, hierarchical processing of uncertainty and the bigger picture if
you could read it gives the functions carried out by
different parts of visual cortex along with what region it
is. And there are bottom up, top down
horizontal interactions and and as the figure says, the
bottom up horizontal and top down interactions overcome complementary processing
deficiencies. So if it weren't for them, those
interactions nothing could be completed effectively. And moreover,
each of the processes do what one's called multiplexing information
. So a visual boundary, it's not just an
edge. If you know, I the the famous
example of a shaded ellipse, if all it was
was a bounding edge at the instead of a boundary
, then the color inside would just fill in and
you'd see a flat gray ellipse, but boundaries respond
to edges, texture shading and depth. And so
, um in addition to hierarchical resolution of uncertainty with
all these interactions, each of the computations are multiplexing
, multiple properties. And as I said before,
otherwise, you couldn't, I couldn't ever learn to
recognize your face. You know, you have texture
, you have shading, you have boundaries. Um
It's all overlaid. I have to be able to
deal with it holistically. Did that help? No
. Yes, that helped. And uh earlier or
just a minute ago, actually, you mentioned how
uh many theories of consciousness out there, people,
apparently people who propose them apparently do not even look
at uh scientific data. So, but why do
you think there are so many theories of consciousness out
there? And uh would you have a solution for
how we should actually approach it that we all have
a conscious experience? So maybe we feel entitled,
but we also experience cognitive impenetrability, which means that
in our daily experience, if you don't study neuroscience
, you don't even know you have a brain.
And for hundreds of years, people thought that our
experience was in our pancreas or our liver or you
know, so um you can't introspect the answer.
Mhm And so I don't believe that a theory which
discusses consciousness is a theory of consciousness. Unless it
can show how interacting brain processes give rise to conscious
psychological experiences, you have to make the link and
without a linking hypothesis between brain and mind, brain
processes have no functional role and psychological processes have no
mechanistic explanation. So you're high and dry. Now
, as I mentioned, I'm lucky, I started
passionately studying psychology as a 17 year old. And
that drove me because I always think in real time
into studying brain dynamics, I I didn't mention but
I was driven into neural networks to explain data about
verbal learning, serial, verbal learning, how we
learn lists of anything. And I didn't know they
were neural networks. I had never studied, I
was a freshman after all cell bodies of neurons,
axons, synapses, synoptic knobs, transmitters, action
potentials. They were all in my model from a
psychological derivation. And so only when I talked to
pre-med, friends who were studying it in their pre-med
courses that I realized the things that they told me
they're learning, I already knew. So you have
to make that link. And from a very early
age, I discovered a way to penetrate cognitive and
penetrability and people who want to know how I've done
it and others have tried to do it. Um
They should read my book and then if they get
really interested. Um If you go to my web
page, which is just sites, si Tes dot
Bu for Boston university.edu/, Steve Gsteveg sites W to
use flash Steve G, you'll see maybe 570 archival
articles and quite a few videos of self-contained lectures and
interviews to learn more about it in detail. But
my book is one is a good, you know
, one place to go shopping for this information.
There are 17 chapters on different stuff and it covers
a lot of stuff. So yeah, yeah.
So what makes me frustrated with some very well known
scientists? I won't mention like the quantum guys if
they could explain even a tiny fraction of the amount
of data I've explained by that. I mean,
how brain dynamics give rise to parametric psychological experiences in
data. I would think they were making a serious
contribution but they don't even try and, and they
never try to compare their contribution with mine, which
I just feel is unscientific. It's not how I
was brought up beyond bad manners. It's unscientific,
which is the severe criticism in my lexicon. So
let's move ahead here. I I think that earlier
we've already touched on what consciousness is good for and
you've also explained what resonance states and resonance mean.
So I mean, another thing that people many times
bring to the table when talking about consciousness, particularly
the philosophers. And this is something that was coined
, I guess by uh David Chalmers in the nineties
is the hard problem of consciousness. Do you think
that it can be solved scientifically? Well, let
me, um of course, it depends how you
define it. Let me just read first Wikipedia says
, and I'll quote, the hard problem of consciousness
is the problem of explaining how and why we have
quality or phenomenal experiences, um how sensations acquire characteristics
such as colors and taste. So to a certain
extent, and I will come back to this moment
. All my theories do just that. Like my
theory of vision is trying to explain how we see
, you know, boundaries surf, you know,
shading texture, color, all these properties of surfaces
, paintings and so on. But let me just
give another quote from Nagel in 74. He wrote
in part when we see, for example, we
experience visual sensations, the felt quality of redness,
the experience of dark and light, the quality of
depth in a visual field. Other experiences go along
with perception and different modalities, the sound of a
clarinet, the smell of mothballs. Well, um
one can give a scientific explanation of what's going on
in your brain when you see red, dark and
light depth, um sounds of instruments, but no
theory in science that's defined by mathematical equations as all
scientific theories to the present have can experience the color
red or any other conscious qualia equations don't have qualia
. But in other sciences um like I I love
this uh quote after you've read Lamb's huge treatise on
hydrodynamics, you still don't know that water is wet
, but you know, just about everything you'd ever
wanna know about water and other fluids, including air
um to design airplanes that fly boats that float on
the surface of marines. You have an effective understanding
of water and the fact that you don't know it's
wet matters less and less because you can give a
scientific explanation of what is happening. First, what
characterizes the state of a liquid versus a gas versus
solid through the molecular theory of gasses and this and
that and the other thing. So it just doesn't
matter after a while. And so in my life
, given what I know that I know um the
fact that I'm seeing beautiful colors around me, I
can understand a lot of how that is happening and
it is outside what an equation I can give you
representations of the objects and the colors and their forms
and their brightnesses. But I can't say why it
looks red. I can't because an equation can't do
that. And the the, but the answer is
an equation can't do that in any science. You
know, there's this famous um uh example, I
hope I'm remembering it right? You know, when
um astronauts were coming down and landing and they landed
somewhere in, I don't know, Arizona or wherever
or wherever, there was a flat arid surface.
And the first thing I guess maybe these were the
first guys to the moon. I don't remember.
But the, the, the anecdote is the first
thing they said when they got out was the bump
, was there? Meaning that the computation of their
trajectory coming in to the atmosphere predicted there would be
a little bump and it was there. But that's
not the same thing as the qualia uh f experiencing
the bump. Uh So science can be effective and
useful, but I do think it's outside the province
of equations to say why water feels wet, you
know, we can say why a fluid has certain
properties but why it feels wet. I, I
don't think equations can do and if someone can,
I, I will study them passionately. I don't
see how it can be done in principle though.
Mhm So uh let's talk here a little bit about
some of the applications of the way you approach consciousness
in your book. Before, toward the end,
we talk a little bit about uh principles of brain
design and some other general questions. So do you
think that your approach to consciousness would have any implications
for the way we understand mental disorders? Well,
um this is one of the things I call an
acquired taste, just like consciousness was an acquire taste
. It's not something I ever dreamed I'd have anything
to offer. Um But so all of the neural
models start by studying the brain dynamics and mental functions
of normal or typical individuals because there are vast databases
on that, you know, many hundreds thousands of
scientists. Like if you go to the annual meeting
of the Society for Neuroscience, I think a recent
meeting at 26,000 scientists, they're all doing incredible work
, huge databases. But at a certain point,
I noticed that if some of the processes get imbalanced
or damaged in specific ways, then I could see
formal behavioral symptoms of mental disorders emerged. And,
you know, I just had to notice that it
was in the model. Uh And so it's in
this spirit, I've so far explained behavioral symptoms based
on precisely defined imbalances. Remember, complementary computing is
a balancing act or, or actual lesions in Alzheimer's
disease, autism, uh Fragile X syndrome, schizophrenia
, medial temporal amnesia, visual and auditory amnesia and
neglect and problems of slow wave sleep. So that
came in through the back door just like all of
it is. So the moral of the story for
young scientist is uh don't look for shortcuts, uh
try to understand the underlying principles and designs. Uh
And then try to model it in an authentic and
serious way. It's hard work. Uh Sometimes I
wasn't ready to even write down anything about a problem
for 10 or 20 years until I'd accumulated enough uh
information to be able to proceed. But then uh
I like saying it's the gift that keeps on giving
consciousness was part of the gift that kept on giving
, understanding a little bit of mental disorder is part
of the gift that kept on giving. So if
you try to get to the heart of the matter
, it's richness will reward you many times over.
But I've been lucky because I started very young.
And even though it's controversial for quite a few years
before neural networks were even a thing, there were
always enough people in Washington who had faith in me
and the work to give us enough funding to do
the work. And it's not like the kind of
funding where you need 50 million to get a fancy
machine. All the money that supported me paid for
uh graduate fellows ships and postdocs uh for people to
learn from me and learn to do science with me
. So it's pennies on the dollar was a good
investment anyway. Um Did that say enough about that
? Mhm. Uh And another topic that you also
cover in your book is irrational decisions. What is
, what is an irrational decision exactly? And why
do we make them? Well, you know,
there are several different kinds and uh let me just
make a comment before I focus on one kind in
general. If a decision fails to achieve one's goal
, when another decision that would achieve the goals readily
available, it wasn't chosen. We may want to
say they were being irrational, you know, and
just like in cognitive emotional interactions, you might have
feelings about stuff and you just can't bring yourself to
do it. Uh And there are many factors that
can cause it, including an experience with this kind
of decision making or the need to make a quick
decision around the stress. You know, there are
speed accuracy, trade-off problems. But the most famous
psychological database concerns what's called decision making under risk.
That is decisions in situations that are uncertain because the
outcomes are defined by probabilities. You know, if
you do this and that the probability of getting this
payoff is that if you do that and this the
probability of getting that pay off is that and which
do people choose? And um Danny Conman and Amos
Tversky won the Nobel Prize in Economics in 2002 for
their experiments in an algebraic model. They published to
fit that data in 1979 explaining paradoxical properties of irrational
decision making in probabilistic environments and their algebraic model,
which is, you know, phenomenological model that tries
to compress the description of the data. And it
is very useful, it's called prospect theory. But
then in 1987 I think my student, Bill Gutowski
and I uh went beyond it in a uh well
known article in psychological review. Uh because my article
with Bill introduced a real time neural network model,
we gave it a name because I started realizing you
got to name everything you don't need to prevent other
people from plagiarizing it. I won't stop them.
But at least you could say that's just uh affective
balance theory is what we called it that quantitatively explains
and simulated the Danny Kamman and Amos Tversky data as
emergent properties. And all we did was we applied
my already known cognitive emotional model to that data.
So we didn't do any more modeling. We showed
that their data fell out of the wash when the
model was exposed to the kind of risky environments like
those in prospect theory. So that I thought had
an important lesson that Darwinian selection does shape our mind
to be adaptive, but it it fails in certain
environments. Um You know, it can't anticipate every
kind of risky environment. And in the same spirit
in chapter 17, in my book, I summarize
other examples of irrational behaviors including superstitious and self punitive
behaviors in a similar way how in certain environments,
you know, and you know, um conspiratorial thinking
, sadly how certain social environments can support conspire uh
conspiracy kind of ideas which we see all too much
in the United States these days to say. So
my abstract with Bill I, I summarize a little
here. These explanations illustrate that the data concerning decision
making under risk may now be related to data concerning
the dynamics of condition and cognition and emotion as consequences
of single psychophysiological theory. So in other words,
you didn't have to build a new theory and it
really, and we explained some risky decision making data
that common and Tversky could not like pref what's called
preference reversals. So our theory is more powerful both
in the sense of um uh explaining their data as
the merchant properties of known brain on the motional dynamics
, but also explaining more data because Bill, you
know, didn't experiment uh on the uh preference reversals
. But you know, our paper was published in
87 uh Danny and Amos was in 79 They got
the Nobel Prize in 2002. We didn't share it
. So go figure. Well, uh so we've
already also touched on the or addressed the problem of
cognitive impenetrability. So let's talk about something that we
, you've alluded to in the beginning of our conversation
, that is A I system. So do you
think that having a better understanding of our brains give
rise to minds would also be important for designing A
I systems? Well, you know, today,
when people say the word A I, they usually
mean neural networks, which wasn't the case when A
I was symbolic, Marvin Minsky realized he ought to
get on the gravy train. In fact, there's
a funny anecdote about that. Uh Marvin Minsky and
Seymour Pappert when they were doing symbolic A I,
they were at MIT and I was an assistant professor
and they really attacked me brutally because I was doing
neural networks. And Marvin when he was a young
man tried to do neural networks and he failed.
And since Marvin was the smartest man in the world
. How can this little dipshit kid be allowed to
do neural networks? They attacked me. Anyway,
years later, after I'd found it and became first
president of the International Neural Network Society and the Archival
journal neural Networks. And I was veteran chief for
many years, I had a lot of influence over
the organization of international conferences on neural networks. And
I said, let's invite Marvin Minsky because he had
just written his book Society of Mind, which basically
was just plagiarism. But hey, that was nothing
new for the People in Tech Square. And I
figured, let's hear what Marvin has to say.
Sadly, Marvin ever prepared. Um But he got
up and the first thing he said was there are
two things I regret in my life. One was
I underestimated gross Burt. And then he, the
rest of his presentation was telling jokes, he wasn't
prepared poor Marvin. He was such an egotist amazing
. And you know, he did some useful earlier
work and then he just, you know, shoveled
in the guilt anyway. Uh What can I say
? So my neural networks illustrate autonomous adaptive intelligence and
not all neural networks do. So I was trying
to say now when people say neural networks or a
I, they usually mean deep learning. And uh
I published a paper a few years ago because I
was invited to where I explain why deep learning is
untrustworthy because it's not explainable. Mm If you make
a prediction, using deep learning and let's say it's
a medical prediction and someone dies as a result.
And the surviving family are grief stricken and they say
, why did you tell the doctor to do that
? And your answer would be, I don't know
, you're gonna be sued out for everything you're worth
. So it's untrustworthy because is unexplainable and it's unreliable
because it can experience catastrophic forgetting. In fact,
in 1988 I wrote a off sighed paper that I
review in my magnum opus with 17 prop problems that
back propagation which deep learning uses as its learning engine
still has that art never had and yet they still
choose not to use it. So deep learning is
deeply flawed and then chat GP t you know,
a generative A I, I mean, you know
, they've thrown into it immense databases, they scrub
the internet. And so perhaps not surprisingly, it
can generate a lot of phrases and sentences that sound
intelligent. But basically, you know, it starts
with a sentential context and has a probabilistic algorithm for
trying to guess what to say next. The foundational
problems are, it has no goals, it has
no meaning and it literally does not know what it's
talking about literally. And in fact, um on
the connections website now, I don't know if you
follow it. There's been this very heated discussion of
this uh attack uh on A I of this kind
led by Gary Marcus who's a professor at NYU and
everything they're saying against it is correct. But I
believe the future of humanity will benefit from an A
I that is increasingly autonomous, adaptive and intelligent in
its algorithms, machines and mobile robots, especially ones
that embody brain inspired designs because these are the ones
that can seamlessly interact in brain machine uh um co-operative
ventures. And I'm the guy who's led that and
we're well on the way to it in terms of
meaning, you know, I don't want to presume
that everything's understood. In fact, just last year
I published an article on my web page about how
Children learn in real time from their parents and other
teachers to learn effective and perceptual language meanings. It's
not in my book. I wasn't ready to write
that paper till last year and that's just the beginning
of what has to be a huge a research program
that I clearly will not live to see completed.
But at least now there's that foundation you can't say
as people in a, I used to do all
the time with the best game in town. They've
never been the best game in town, but they
spend so much time marketing with people like me,
spend so much time thinking and writing and discovering I
, I can't do that. That's not why I
wanna stay alive. Um Yeah. So should I
say, uh maybe I'll say, you know,
the best example of autonomous adaptive intelligence is the human
mind. We're autonomous because we can act on our
own. We're adaptive because we can learn throughout life
because we solve the stability plasticity dilemma. And we're
intelligent. Hm, at least in the sense that
we can as a species make wise enough decisions and
plans to create civilizations, even though we can be
superstitious, conspiratorial, terribly cruel and violent as well
. And the end of my book discusses, you
know, why they and you know, there's a
kind of Yin Yang in the human mind and good
and evil are built right into us. But I
also try to clarify why good has a a leg
up. Um because bad things usually pub punished and
either suppressed or avoided where you can, good things
can be sustained and you can build beautiful things,
important, useful things on them. So there's a
broken symmetry and evolution between good and evil and our
lives depend on it. Uh So talking about good
and evil and you also mentioned a little bit earlier
. Superstition. Uh does the approach that you present
in the book will also have implications for how we
understand things like morality, religion, creativity and the
human condition where I guess many of these topics are
traditionally uh approached in philosophy. Yeah. Well,
um remember that Newton thought he was doing natural philosophy
when you do deep science, it gets philosophical,
deep philosophical. Um Well, I wanna do a
quote chapter 17 in my book, likely discusses some
of these, the things they could be discussed much
more, more extensively on page 621 of the header
of this section in question is more or less what
I was just talking about symmetry breaking of positive and
negative in cognition and emotion, coal and a reason
for hope. I think hope is an important word
and especially in our crazy world. Let me just
quote it. It's not too long as with all
predictive behaviors. There are cognitive and emotional reasons for
morality that are built into the most basic properties of
our brains in both cognition and emotion. There is
, I'll argue a broken symmetry between positive and negative
processes with the positive emphasized because it is just a
broken symmetry. Much as every source of light can
cast a shadow, both good and evil deeds are
possible. Although I would claim there's a built in
bias toward the good so that values aren't purely relative
. And as I was just indicating, uh an
example of the broken symmetry is that bad deeds are
punished and punishment suppresses behavior uh which causes us to
avoid them. Uh And if you don't avoid them
, you end up in jail or worse, whereas
good deeds are rewarded and thus can be sustained and
built upon. Um And I believe in that very
much, you know, it's a broken symmetry that's
not very romantic, but I think understanding it,
you know, you don't have to understand much more
than on the level I said is very clarifying a
lot of our development and evolution due to broken symmetries
. Um you know, and just look at us
, we're bilaterally symmetric but with broken, you know
, we have a dominant hemisphere in our cortex,
uh we can be right handed or left handed.
So we are broken but we are symmetric and is
built into everything. And I believe that a lot
of uh the origin of the universe, although I
shouldn't talk about things I know nothing about. I
, well, not, not that I know nothing
but I think a lot of broken symmetries drove evolution
. So, so uh let's uh we've already also
talked earlier about the brain design principles that you uh
uh go through in the book Complementarity and Certainty and
Resonance. So perhaps let, let's go back to
the very beginning of our conversation when I asked you
about when psychology slash neuroscience and physics diverged in terms
of their approach to the brain and the mind.
Do you think that the paradigm you present in your
book can help unify them again? Well, let
me quote again from my book and then if uh
maybe I'll make some other comments on pages 635 and
636. Again, chapter 17, as I explained
in chapter five, brains can also bind into coherent
moments of conscious experience within a unified self measurements taken
from multiple physical sources light sound pressure, temperature,
bodily biochemical processes and the like. Um so like
when someone asks, how do you feel today?
You can tell them all sorts of stuff. And
it's not just like, you know, I have
a light meter, a sound meter, a pressure
meter, it's all unified into a coherent moment of
conscious awareness. So the brain is also a universal
. Remember I talk a little about that self organizing
measurement system of the world and in the world.
Um chapter one explained that due to this universal measurement
process, brains may play a role that'll be compared
with the role played by played in physics by Max
Planck's law of black body radiation. Cause by describing
a radiation spectrum that's universal across all matter planks,
lushes and quantum mechanics. Whereby to explain all subatomic
phenomena, the brain's universal measurement process can be expected
to have a comparable impact on future science. So
, you know, we don't, our brains don't
function when it comes to cognition, emotion, et
cetera on a quantum level. Um you know,
even if there are uh noisy fluctuations in individual cells
, often cell populations have mean activities uh that are
much larger than the variants. So we can have
a a kind of um uh deterministic or mean field
dynamic equations or operating dynamics that's not operating uh with
quantum fluctuations uh needed to be considered. But we
have this universality in terms of all these physical fields
as a measurement device that's self organizing. And I
um also in chapter 17, talk about how some
of these principles um like complementarity uncertainty and resonance operate
even in single non neural cells, a a very
primitive uh cell types that have existed long before humans
. So there is a universal developmental code in which
art adaptive resonance is part of that larger code.
It is one example of the kind of resonance that
you find uh even in morphogenesis of very simple species
. Um So, you know, I talk about
the kind of resonance that occurs when a blastula becomes
a gastro, I talk about. Um uh well
, you know, read the book, I'm getting
a little worn out of my search and my brain
isn't. So there is a universal developmental code that
um that includes the things that we experience when our
brains start actually enabling us to remember what we know
about the world. And resonance goes way way back
in morphosis. And you know, I've always thought
, but you know, maybe if someone makes this
precise or shows its wrong, I've always thought of
um the double helix as an example of complementary computing
. And you know, Barbara mcclintock got the Nobel
Prize for showing it's very dynamic. Um So,
you know, if that is properly thought of as
an example of complementary computing, uh There are many
examples of this kind of complementarity uh throughout all of
life, um et cetera, et cetera, et
cetera. Uh And as I say, you know
, when, um so for example, some of
the competitive dynamics I discuss like mass action recurrent on
center off around networks competition uh is universal, not
only when you think of it on the species level
, a a Darwin, but it also occurs at
every level of cellular organization. Uh So the aggregation
of slime molds is an example of a competitive dynamic
with an on center of surround recurrent network. Uh
So there were these universal computational principles that are not
only about us that are also about all living things
. And you know, when I read theoretical physics
, which I've been doing since I was a boy
, you know, I see what I view as
physical versions of on center of surround networks galaxy as
it were, you know, it's a balance balancing
act, but I can't say anything useful about that
. So, uh let me just ask you one
last question then and I want to ask you this
because I also, I actually found it very interesting
that you talk about this in the book and whenever
people in science talk about laws many times, uh
I mean, people get upset about talking about laws
that are not laws of physics, I mean laws
of biology, psychology or whatever. I mean,
people are not usually very fond of that. But
do you think that we can actually talk about laws
of cell biology? Well, cell biology is vast
and these days he biology usually means genetics. And
uh I'm not a geneticist, although I did just
make a very speculative comment about the double helix.
Um So I'm not sure what context to put the
question, you know, it is part of cell
biology. What I said about um uh slime mold
aggregation, their cells, their biology, the growth
of hydrous heads, their cells. It's biology in
that sense, there are examples of shared laws,
um you know, gastro relation, it's cell biology
, it's not in a brain, there is no
brain yet. So um I feel, you know
, even my work has shown that what I'm doing
is a special case of more general laws that you
can see reflected in examples of cells in biology.
But um if you, if what you mean is
genetics, then I'm not a geneticist, but it
does strike me that the double helix. Uh and
for all I know it's being done, maybe the
stuff that Barbara mcclintock got started is maybe being studied
very actively and I just don't read about it in
terms of the dynamics of those complimentary strands. Um
you know, complementary computing generally gives you a form
of stability. You know, the Yin and the
Yang alone aren't enough but together and bound by the
right kind of feedback. They can give you stable
organization just like with the boundaries and surfaces, for
example, like with the water and West streams,
one of the great triumphs of the watch stream,
which I try to explain through models is how you
develop invariant recognition categories, size and variant view and
variant position variant. So I could recognize you from
any view, distance angle, you know. But
the problem with being position and variant is at the
place where you're computing this and the anterior of infra
temporal cortex, I have no idea where your face
is in space. And that's what the, so
that's in the W stream, the West stream gives
a spatial representation. So you have to be able
to go from an invariant representation into the watch stream
into a variant position representation in the West stream.
And I explain how that happens. Um uh But
by themselves, you know, you'd have positions without
objects and objects, you didn't know where they are
. So each of them is useful and important,
but it's not enough his survival. So complementary computing
on every level of our brains is necessary for survival
. And it may very well be uh at every
level of cell biology. But I'm not a person
who studied non brainin cell systems for long enough to
make a strong comment. I'd love to know more
about it. Maybe I'll do more of that.
Uh In my remaining years. I don't know.
Well, uh there are many other topics that of
course, we could cover here because the book is
massive and very detailed. And again, it is
the conscious mind resonant brain how, which brain makes
a mind and I'm leaving a link in the description
to it and I hope that my audience runs and
buys it. It's a very interesting book. And
uh Steve, apart from the book, would you
like to tell people where they can find you and
your work on the internet? Oh, yes.
So I had mentioned once, but let me say
again, I have a personal web page sites,
si tes dot bu.edu. So sites Boston University Education
slash Steve Gsteveg. Um uh All my articles can
be downloaded from there and quite a few interviews and
uh some videos of keynote lectures on different topics.
Um And if anyone wants to write me with a
question about my work, my email is simple.
It's just Steve Steve at bu.edu. Steve at bu.edu
. So I love to discuss science. And um
um what can I say? I started 67 years
ago and I'm still at it. And um and
that's a testimony and I only need to my good
luck but to really respect the foundations of what I
was studying and not go for shortcuts and they've thrust
me forward. So I never hit a brick wall
. And uh I've loved every minute of it even
though it's been really hard work. Well. And
uh thank you so much for that work and it's
been an immense pleasure to have you on the show
. Thank you so much for accepting the invitation.
Thank you for inviting me and I'll look forward to
getting the URL for it so I can uh hope
I don't cringe too much. No, it was
great. It was great. So, thank you
again. My pleasure. Hi guys. Thank you
for watching this interview. Until the end. If
you liked it, please share it. Leave a
like and hit the subscription button. The show is
brought to you by N Lights Learning and development.
Then differently check the website at N lights.com and also
please consider supporting the show on Patreon or paypal.
I would also like to give a huge thank you
to my main patrons and paypal supporters, Perera Larson
, Jerry Muller and Frederick Suno, Bernard Seche O
of Alex Adam, Castle Matthew Whitting B no Wolf
, Tim Ho Erica LJ Connors, Philip Forrest Connolly
. Then the Met Robert Wine in NAI Z Mark
Nevs calling in Holbrook Field. Governor Mikel Stormer Samuel
Andre Francis for Agns Ferger, Ken Herz J and
Lain Jung Y and the Samuel K Hes Mark Smith
J. Tom Hummel Sran, David Sloan Wilson Yasa
, Dear Roman Roach Diego, Jan Punter Romani Charlotte
Bli Nicole Barba Adam Hunt Pavlo Stass, Nale Me
, Gary G Alman, Samos, Ari and YPJ
Barboza Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Broner Douglas Fry
Franka Gilon Cortez or Solis Scott Zachary. Ftw Daniel
Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgino, Luke Loki
, Georgio, Theophano Chris Williams and Peter Wo David
Williams Di A Costa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex
Chao Marie Martinez. Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore Fist,
Larry Dey Junior, Old Einon Starry Michael Bailey.
Then Spur by Robert Grassy Zorn. Jeff mcmahon,
Jake Zul Barnabas Radis Mark Temple, Thomas Dvor Luke
Neeson, Chris Tory Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin Gilbert Jessica
. No, Linda Brendan Nicholas Carlson, Ismael Bensley
Man, George Katis Valentine Steinman, Perlis Kate Van
Goler, Alexander Abert Liam Dan Biar Masoud Ali Mohammadi
Perpendicular J Ner Urla. Good enough Gregory Hastings David
Pins of Sean Nelson, Mike Levin and Jos Net
. A special thanks to my producers is our web
, Jim Frank Luca Stuffin, Tom Veg and Bernard
N Cortes Dixon, Bendik Muller Thomas Trumble, Catherine
and Patrick Tobin, John Carlman, Negro, Nick
Ortiz and Nick Golden. And to my executive producers
, Matthew Lavender, Si, Adrian Bogdan Knits and
Rosie. Thank you for all.